You enter a space of wonder and mystery.
Space where code writes itself,
space where programs act independently.
Where the mystic and efficiency collide.
You are now ready for meta-programming.
[MUSIC]
Diego, are you okay?
>> Hi Julia.
Yeah, I'm doing quite well.
I'm just talking about meta-programming.
>> But meta-programming isn't magical,
it's just a little tricky.
Also, why are we in black and white.
[SOUND] That's better.
>> Yeah, you know what Julia?
You're right.
Meta-programming
is something that you've
likely seen in action before.
It's the process of writing
code that writes more code.
And it's more common
than you would expect.
>> In the following lesson you're
going to learn about the ways that Ruby
uses Meta-programming to
make coding easier for you.
>> You'll also learn how to take
advantage of Ruby Meta-programming
features to solidify your
understanding of the Ruby language and
to help make your code more dry.
>> Let's get started